in Japan summers are hot offices are
stuffy air conditioners are blasting and
using excessive air conditioners means
using an excessive amount of electricity
and energy so this woman launched a
clothing trend that's so cool it's
helping them cut down emissions and save
the planet from overheating plus you get
to wear a new shirt this great big story
was made possible by BP fewer emissions
more energy this is the global energy
challenge this is UT Koko ek the
governor of Tokyo she launched something
called cool biz it's an initiative where
workers swap out their suits for lighter
clothes and not just lighter clothes
very cool shirts and of course cooler
people means less air conditioning
before Yuriko stepped in business people
were not at liberty to wear more casual
clothes my next Thursday night go to the
mall losing that oh oh you go to there
because she's not tonight our caso de
Luca toga
I got a question about the word I could
this is she to cure and encourage them
oh yes - no oh York says - it's not
their little talk
Oh - so then you tell my assistant and a
talk could I know what they was
successful is putting it lightly
since its launch in 2005 cool biz is
everywhere in Japan it's in clothing
stores businesses and even fashion shows
and these CEOs really like their shirts
recorded digitally I said I couldn't not
there
oui maintenant all study committee
Madame I know what the Torah had to yuku
moment as a naked eyes put it on little
kindness to the kamijo don't know yes
details me yeah
according to the environment ministry
they estimate that carbon dioxide
emissions were cut by over one point
sixty nine million metric tons across
the country but for Yuriko Kobus is more
than just an initiative could it be so
well then you can't cure nopony attack
ad wagang myself especially cocoa there
but I stood suma Sakura Morimoto her but
Isis in circuit on Memorial Day
[Music]